[Musik]
ich bin jetzt ein brite und sie
versuchen mich zu überzeugen dass ich
doch in der eu bleiben und dann jetzt
mal richtig mit herzblut gemacht einen
klugen prexl im unterhaus in der
öffentlichkeit denn das chaos würde euch
gewaltigen und uns auch großen schalten
zu finden soll ich jetzt auch so
reagieren wie ein normaler brite
entscheiden sie foto in einer kneipe in
stuttgart ab und sind zum teil auch dna
oder lass mich in ruhe könnte man es
vielleicht so machen man zieht den br-
exit durch und dafür schließt sich die
eu großbritannien an
die briten wollten hier raus also
wollten sich von uns entfernen
das werde ich die gedanken machten sie
nicht wirklich wahrscheinlich
ich glaube eher dass in 15 jahren eine
neue generation hat dritten den erneuten
eintritt beschließen wird sind wir
deutschen vielleicht auch gegen den
dragset weil wir wissen wie teuer so
eine wiedervereinigung irgendwann mal
werden kann
nein wir deutsche isabella mehrzahl
wollen die deutschen dass die briten
geblieben wären
und wir gucken auch gern die hochzeiten
wenn ich sie vielleicht wir haben in
einer demokratie zu akzeptieren dass ein
referendum mit einer mehrheit
entschieden hat rauszugehen gut ist es
ja eine freie entscheidung mit dem kopf
gegen die wand zu laufen wir aber gefahr
und klug ich bin einmal die heiß berührt
macht das nicht mehr
na ja ich würde gern noch da es ja doch
wahrscheinlich ist dass die briten die
eu verlassen mit ihnen das letzte
interview auf englisch führen
also ich kann eigentlich sehr gut nur
ist so blöd mich sein ist auf die
englisch reden
ich kann sehr schlecht englisch deswegen
bin ich auch froh dass sie so gut können
dann ganz gut aber ich habe es nicht
löst beim deutschen fernsehen im zweiten
deutschen fernsehen ist reden wir sind
auch viel auf youtube schön feucht was
würden sie die visa mehr für einen tipp
geben das nicht meine aufgabe
ich habe viel respekt sie tanzt ja sogar
auch sehr gut ist ihre sache ich das ja
auch
sowohl wiener walzer foxtrott wie rock'n
roll haben mit diesen worten zurück ins
studio